Alright guys, let's talk about the one pager, what we need to absolutely include.
I'm gonna call this the 1.2 million dollar template and the reason why is because I have
literally spent that much money on Google at the time of recording this and by doing
that, I've been able to test a lot of things on landing pages.
I've been able to test if the picture should go here, if the website or if the quote form
should go right there, what questions we should ask, how big should the phone number be, where
should we put this.
I've tested all that stuff over the course of 1.2 million dollars and I'm going to show
you the template that if you can replicate this, you are going to be fine.
You can add your own little flavors, but I'm gonna go over some of the non-negotiables
that you must include on this one page template.
Again, this is something you have to do right once, so take your time, just like the keyword
list.
Do the keyword list correctly.
Do the one pager well the first time and guess what?
Next time, you just copy and paste, you swap out the, hey, instead of concrete, it's tree
surface.
Instead of tree surface, it's this, okay?
You swap out the phone number, maybe you swap out the colors, swap out the pictures and
the content, done, done and done.
Okay, so take your time and make this really, really good.
All right, guys, so here you can see a quick example of what I would consider a perfect
landing page.
I know some of you guys that are coming from WordPress backgrounds or you have the design
out, you're like, oh my gosh, this?
Like this right here?
Yes, this, okay?
Let me tell you about this, okay?
You're looking at albuquerqueconcrete.weebly.com.
I built this, actually I didn't, my team built this website a year and two months ago, okay?
We did our regular process that we teach in here, we ran ads, we went and found a business
owner, we closed the deal, awesome, okay?
And something happened and that is I forgot to follow up and have my project manager build
the actual website.
We got the deal and we forgot to build the website, okay?
So about, oh, was it about a month and a half ago, I reached out to Francesca and I said,
Francesca, give me a rankings report on these cities, okay?
And so she went through and one of the cities was albuquerqueconcrete.
So I was looking at the rankings report and I said, oh, where's the rankings for that
one?
Because I was just looking at that client.
And she said, yeah, I was gonna tell you about that, she's like, we don't have a website
for that one.
I'm like, what do you mean we don't have a website for that one?
She's like, yeah, we don't have a website for that one.
We've been running ads to the one pager for a year.
So guys, I had done the deal at whatever, let's call it a thousand bucks, I can't remember
the exact specifics on that deal, a thousand bucks.
I was spending 500, and in this case, I think it was even less.
And I was making the difference, 500 to 700 dollars of profit the entire time, even though
I didn't have a website.
I just set up the ads and I was pushing the leads and I had the credit card involved and
I was arbitraging this thing.
So I know this doesn't look great.
I know it's like, this is very basic.
I know, I know, I know, but guess what?
It works.
It works, it works, it works, and it will produce leads.
So let's take a look at some of the things you have to include, okay?
Number one, I'm just gonna show you, and you guys are free to go build your one pager on
Wix, Wordpress, I don't care, it doesn't actually matter.
And I'm not gonna spend time going in and showing you how to use a web builder, because
guys, it's not hard.
You literally go and drag stuff over, like you drag a picture over, you drag the content
down.
It's not difficult, okay?
Couple things I'm gonna show you, and these are like non-negotiable.
So number one is the phone number.
The phone number needs to be the centerpiece of this website.
So as you can see here on the screen, it is the centerpiece, it's the thing that pops,
and honestly, I think it could be even a little bit bigger.
Do not, and I understand, most websites, they have the big writing, it says Albuquerque
Concrete, like this big, right?
And then the phone number is this little teeny thing, probably not even underneath, it's
up in the corner, because it looks sleek, okay?
And guess what, I don't care about sleek, I care about freaking making money, and in
order to make money, phone needs to rain, okay?
So what I'm gonna do is, you need to start thinking about the customer.
If you have a customer looking for concrete, quit making it difficult for them to call
you.
Quit making it difficult for them to get ahold of you, to ask for an estimate.
So everything that you do, the psychology here is, how do we make this as easy as possible
for somebody looking for concrete to call us, and therefore grabbing that lead?
And one of the things is, making that phone number right there in their face, and the
last thing I want to point out on this phone number, is it's a click to call.
Meaning, I highlighted it, and I did a call, an action button, which means if they click
on it, it's immediately going to call directly to the phone number, which is the tracking
number, which goes to the business owner.
And the best thing to do there is, I like to, so link it up, make sure it's click to
call, and I like to add an underline.
A lot of times on these web builders, when you make it click to call, it adds the underline.
I am going to tell you right now, go and manually add the underline, because it just triggers
in people's brain, oh, I can click on that, it's a link, it's a phone number.
So that is a click to call, you can see.
So add that.
You honestly, I just include this somewhere on the screen, not as important as the phone
number.
Phone number, that's the number one non-negotiable, needs to be big, bold, center, and it needs
to be click to call.
Next thing is this quote form.
And there's a right way to do this, and there's a wrong way to do this.
One thing that I think helps a lot is with the quote form making it pop.
And one thing that I've found to make it pop is to make it have a background.
Okay, so you can see right here, this isn't just like a quote form that says free instant
quote and it's kind of tucked in the corner, right?
It's not.
It is, it's got a background, it just kind of pops against that white.
So I would encourage you to do the same, okay?
And another couple things about this quote form is make it seem as if when they fill
this out, they put in their information, they put in what concrete surface they need, the
square footage, all that, make it almost seem like as soon as they push get my quote, they're
gonna get an immediate email.
I want it to seem almost like you're gonna open up your email or your text message and
you're gonna have a quote, okay?
That's the psychology behind it.
And guys, we are going to get them an immediate quote because we're gonna call them immediately
or the business owner's gonna call them immediately, okay?
So on the instant quote, make sure it pops.
I like to add the free instant quote, free instant estimate, whatever.
I like to make sure the word instant is in there because I want people thinking, hey,
I can get price quick because they're gonna get price quick, we're gonna call them.
I like to throw a little exclamation point.
You can experiment around with this plus free bonus coupon thing.
I don't even think that's necessary and some people are gonna watch this go, what's the
bonus coupon?
Honestly, I don't even think it's necessary.
So that doesn't matter, okay?
You can include it if you want.
Okay, guys, so there's a few things with this quote form that need to be done right and
you're probably like, I never thought that this much thought went into the quote form.
This much thought goes into the quote form, okay?
So I wanna show you what most people do.
So I just went ahead and I typed in Albuquerque concrete.
I looked at the first person ranking, okay?
It's this company called Duke City, whatever.
Now this is more like a ready mix, whatever.
So I know it's not necessarily the exact same thing but I just wanna prove a point without
spending a ton of time.
If you look, first of all, their quote forms are nowhere to be found, okay?
They're definitely not in that first like fold where you're like, oh, there's the quote
form, let me get a quote.
And side note, good luck finding the phone number.
I don't even see a phone number on here so we're gonna win based on that.
If I wanted to contact these guys, I have to work.
I don't want to make the customer work, okay?
So if you scroll all the way to the bottom, this is what most people do, is contact us,
okay?
Contact us to me as a customer, literally screams, hey, solicit me.
Call me and bug me, okay?
You enter your name, your email, your subject, like that just means they literally put a,
that just means they put no thought into this.
Your subject, what do you mean your subject, right?
And then your message, this is the dumbest thing ever, then it says submit.
This is such a standard BS crap, if you guys do this, I see this, I'm gonna be pissed.
Do not do this.
Contrast that, which is what 99% of people do, oh, good job by the way, Duke, find your
number at the bottom, not click to call, so now I have to go, I have to write it down
and then put it in.
Not a good strategy, but that's a side note, okay?
Go back to this.
Contrast what you just saw with this one.
You look at the bottom, you're looking at the screen, you're like, oh, free instant
quote, okay?
Here's the kicker, instead of just hitting them and saying, hey, free instant quote,
give me your name, your phone number, your email, your address, your this, your that,
your social security number, okay, don't do that, okay?
What you need to do is psychologically, we wanna get them down the rabbit hole a little
bit.
So, the first thing they see is instead of saying, hey, give me your name, we're asking
them a question.
We're saying, what concrete service do you need?
And they can look and go driveway, sidewalk, walkway, patio, okay, well, we were just looking
at, oh, or other, okay, okay, so I'm gonna choose sidewalk.
Approximate size, square footage of project, right, and they're like, I don't really know,
but look, probably more than 100, okay?
Now think about it like this.
The customer's already answered two questions, it says instant, and now we're like, oh, by
the way, give us your name and your phone number and your email, and it says, get my
quote.
This right here is a completely different and psychologically just, it's on point because
we're getting them, and think about it if you're a human, you're like, oh, I've already
answered two of the questions, I may as well just drop in my name and email and get a quote
in the chance that they're gonna just email it to me, right?
They might just email it to me.
So guys, the keys here to look at with this quote is make it pop, okay?
Make sure you ask one to two questions related to that service that almost make it seem like
they're gonna get an instant quote in the form of an email, okay?
Even though they are gonna get an instant quote in the form of a phone call, you almost
want it to be like it's an auto-generated thing, okay?
So ask two questions and then ask for, at the very most, name, phone number, email.
Now I know some people and some business owners are gonna go, hey, can you just get the addresses?
Can you get this?
Can you get that?
Guys, there's a fine line.
You ask too many questions here, people aren't, they're gonna be discouraged.
But when it's the name, phone number, email, things that they literally have memorized
and it's very simple and easy, they're willing to give it after they've answered a couple
questions.
I'm telling you right now, I've tested flipping this and asking for the name, phone number,
email, and then the questions.
I get way better conversion out of this where we ask one, two questions, okay?
And then we go name, phone number, email, boom, get my quote.
Guys, that is the one-pagers.
These are the things that are non-negotiables that have to be included and that is a bold
centered phone number that needs to be underlined, it needs to be clicked to call, okay?
It needs to be the centerpiece of your website.
By the way, at this stage, if you would like to use your cell phone, you can use your cell
phone.
However, I would recommend using a call tracking service so that it's, first of all, not your
phone number.
Second of all, you know that it came from that website.
Have you ever gotten your phone out and you missed calls and you're like, man, I wonder
if they called me from my company website, they called me from this, call me from that.
You don't even know, especially if you have multiple sites feeding into that phone number,
that's gonna get really tricky really quick because when you call, when they call, you're
not gonna know who it is, okay?
So I do recommend using a call tracking service, but it's not necessary if this is your first
project and you're on a thin budget.
I get it.
So make sure that's there.
And then the quote form, and not only the quote form, make sure it pops.
Make sure you ask at least two questions.
So for example, if it was masonry, it could say, you know, you could say, what service
do you need?
Or you could say something like, you could ask a yes, no question.
You could go, like one of the questions we do is, how soon do you need the service?
And we'll have an option that's like, okay, ASAP, within the week, within the month, or
I'm flexible, okay?
You can ask something like that, but ask at least two questions first and then name, phone
number, email, get my quote.
Anything else outside of this, I would just model over this.
You know, I had a couple of photos, whatever, just make it simple.
Lastly, this content, okay?
You do not have to go and write content from scratch.
You do not need to just go and blast out content, look at your keyword list, do the whole thing.
You're actually free to go and swipe this from this website if you're in concrete, from
another website, if you're in another niche, because, you know, taking someone's content,
you're gonna get what they call black box at some point.
If you copy content, you're gonna get in trouble with Google, they're gonna, you know, not
ever let your site rank.
But we're not trying to make the site rank because if you guys understand the process,
as soon as we get the deal, we're gonna use this one to push the traffic to, we're gonna
get the leads, but once we sign the contract, we're then gonna build out our main website
and that's where we're gonna take the time to build the nice content and the nice photos
and make sure that the site looks a little bit more presentable, et cetera.
This is the down and dirty.
Guys, include these things and remember, and by the way, I do have to say, if you would
like to just go and start testing stuff out, you're free to do that, but what I'm showing
you here, as simple as it looks, is a $1.2 million template and I say that because I've
spent that much money testing and tweaking and dragging and changing and this and that
and I've found that if you do it just like this and include these main couple of things,
you are gonna get leads.